ils sont avec nous ce soir et je suis
comme un fou des zones arides kad merad
et patrick bosso toi là bas j'ai compris
ça braille
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vu ça va brasser de kad merad dans
les médias locaux
c'est un jeune paysan ouais mais
attendez jusqu'à du l'avez compris chez
vous fait bien et tu as a déjà vu la
pression comme ça même au 14 juillet
quand j'ai fait la déclasser bras droits
de l'homme devant tous les présidents du
bassin mais tant que j'ai pas eu peur
et là vous mettez la pression et
pourquoi et pourquoi vous faites ça
avait bien que jeune homme fragile je
sors en pimco mal comment le film sort
partout dans toute la france vous voulez
quoi me fragilisé c'est ça le chercher
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
nous tiens
donc mais qui pète les plombs et ça peut
faire le tour du web
ça oui bon bref c'est à présent
s'appelle gates en voilà alors déjà en
at on a deux ou trois indications vie il
décide de monter à paris à la capitale
au salon de l'agriculture pour voir les
dernières c'est une révolution
[Applaudissements]
c'est vous la syrie n'ont connu c'est un
chien parce qu'il sait que là-bas des
nues je ressens vraiment en train de
regarder mon pea effet non pas ça je
t'en supplie à ton se voulait collard
près de bruges contre si tu achètes
place d'un jeu s'appelle gagner du temps
et il veut il va au salon de la culture
donc ça vraiment un jeu plaisant je vais
être obligée de faire un accent
pectoraux excusez-moi fois j'étais un
peu de riz de semoule de vérité de
véracité tracteurs par noah attendait
pas rose à la bombe et décideurs du bien
il arrivait il fait le tour des stands
comme ça il va voir le stand des
trieuses électrique voilà a pas fini on
pourrait s'arrêter là
la pub d'entre eux n'y a pas de doublon
savez la pub de tartu marie besset sud
et donc il va vous arriver devant le
représentant des prises électriques et
dire bonjour monsieur excusez moi de
vous déranger
tu vas faire que de le vendre alors donc
c'est pas dans ces cas mathieu a jugé ce
que j'espère qu'avec une trieuse met
d'accord qui a battu à toulouse devront
en effet pas quand il me dit ah bonjour
monsieur oui bonjour monsieur un peu des
renseignements mais le match là je vois
ça l'air de bien marcher
ça semble bien je voyais à est ce que
par hasard parce que je vois qu'ils
allaient les 6 pi de la bâche qui sont
en action est ce que par hasard ça
pourrait marcher sur cinq pee wee a et
les habitudes d'écouté au monsieur
pas de problème a priori je pense
qu'après il s'en va il est ok d'accord
il fait le tour du pays va voir d'autres
s'en va là le stand et les fromages pas
machin il revient vous étiez assez long
et je vais aller jusqu'au bout et il
arrive et donc la série bones est mieux
là ça va mal et là
déjà qu'il a du bon on a croisé trois
puis revient évidemment valérie wii du
jeu sauf que s'intéresse alors comment
cela sera bien est-ce qu éventuellement
c'est ça peut marcher sur le doping et
le type me dis bah écoute et gaëtan oui
si ça marche fort 6 pi sur 5 pi sur
trois pistes ça peut marcher sur deux
pieds et dyala c'était bien il s'en va
il revient rappel fait le tour du salon
sans gêne un peu timide comme ça il va
voir le il va voir le vendeur de traits
physiques bon n'en dit pas plus d'accord
vous finirez cette bague dans un instant
hélas gaëtan il revient non il revient
pas à temps j'en suis j'en suis déjà
j'en suis à deux puis trois puis nous
appelle 3 pi donc gheit en attend
cajetan il arrivé dix ans mais si ça
marche avec non j'en ai usa belge mehdi
pourquoi j'ai raconté cette histoire à
la télévision évidemment maintenant
c'est maintenant j'ai plus de 18 19 ans
on va dans un club en vacances une fille
qui me plaît je sais pas comment faire
je n'ose pas le dire
déjà je m'appelle kaddour c'est déjà
commencer à flipper des origines tous
ces commentaires je m'appelle françois
déjà prendre commande soit si le
problème est arrivé tu vois déjà quand
même c'est pas nouveau si ce n'est pas
l'eau et donc j'y explique que voilà en
france je suis quelqu'un de connu donc
faut sauter ou choquer en tunisie en
vacances je sais que j'en ai je dit que
j'étais un producteur de cinéma je sais
pas quoi c'est le français ça plein je
crois que si elle me regarda peau et je
dis voilà tu verra sans doute à
l'aéroport il y aura des photographes
qui vont attendre j'ai appelé mes potes
aller
mais c'est vrai en plus gérer une bande
de potes à l'époque était une bonne
dizaine en partie tout le temps vacances
j'en dis voilà les gars arrivée à
l'aéroport vous arrivez vaut un père vos
appareils jetables vos pages tab aux
appareils photo et il te donnera des je
t'aime aussi et j'arrive je sors je sors
je vais pour aller chercher des valises
et août
françois impression soit est pendante
ouvrit françois bouvet ces prélats
pendant tout le trajet
tu vois de trucs jusqu'au valises les
gens me voyaient passer un groupe de
gens qui sait c'est quoi un jour de fou
tout ce que tu veux
en fait c'est bon par contre en sortant
du parking j'avais une heure quinze
oui je vous l'avais shopping impôts qui
traînent par terre et l'allemagne au
volant comme ça et vous l'avez choper ou
pas jamais de la vie jamais
[Applaudissements]